el pájaro está liberado Esta es la
primera declaración de Iron Man es como
nuevo jefe de Twitter el multimillonario
de la tecnología cumple todo el juego de
su dilata la compra del gigante de las
redes sociales lo que le sitúa al frente
de una de las principales plataformas de
discurso global tras cerrar el acuerdo
de 44 mil millones de dólares más que
inmediatamente están por su autoridad
despidiendo al consejo delegado al
director financiero y al asesor jurídico
jefe de la empresa el trigo fue acusado
por más de engañar a los inversores
sobre el número de cuentas falsas de
Twitter por lo que intentó cancelar la
compra en julio Pero Twitter respondió
con una demanda obligando al Magnate a
revivir su plan de adquisición antes de
la fecha límite este viernes se prometí
una sacudida más no ha ocultado que
quiere ver menos límites en el contenido
publicado algo que hizo que personas
como el ex presidente Donald Trump
fueran vetadas de la plataforma el jefe
de teslais Six dice que hizo la compra
para que las futuras civilizaciones
entren en debates sin recurrir a la
violencia actualmente existe un gran
peligro de que los medios sociales se
fragmentan en cámaras de eco de extrema
derecha y extrema izquierda que generen
más sodio y dividan a nuestra sociedad
pero los críticos dicen que tendrá que
determinar rápidamente en conjunto claro
de directrices en torno a la moderación
de contenidos y la libertad de expresión
si quiere evitar los mismos problemas a
los que se ha enfrentado la directiva de
Twitter hasta ahora los usuarios más
activos de Twitter ya están gravitando
hacia contenidos desagradables y no
seguros para la marca y un menor número
de restricciones podría grabar ese
problema Y hacer que los anunciantes
sean aún menos propensos a gastar en la
plataforma
a pesar de la confusión interna ligada a
los temores de despidos masivos y el
desmantelamiento de la cultura de la
empresa los líderes de Twitter han
acogido esta semana la llegada de más y
su mensaje